merci jean louis ibres l'applaudir bien
je voudrais vous faire observer qu'un
parti politique nationale s'occupe d'un
thème qui nous geste qui nous est cher
la ruralité
on avait tendance et on a toujours
tendance et notamment les socialistes à
considérer que nous sommes des ploucs
que nous sommes des besoins et ben non
c'est 80% de la population qui vit sur
le territoire rural et à nous
aujourd'hui de montrer la considération
qu'on porte à ce territoire avec
l'ensemble des acteurs des
parlementaires mais vous entendrez un
certain nombre d'acteurs qui vont
s'exprimer et notre robuste et objectif
aujourd'hui c'est de montrer que nos
territoires ruraux ont une capacité de
vivre c'est un problème de société comme
on place la ruralité aujourd'hui dans
notre territoire national voilà on va
parler de ça et vous verrez des
propositions concrètes que nous
souhaitons faire dans l'avenir avec
notamment les pronostics de démographie
médicale de normes
j'y reviendrai bonne écoute et puis
voilà on va laisser la place aux
intervenants